. Let's hear from a few more people on
the David Pakman show Discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord.
That is d i. S c o r d.
Let me bring on our friend Bizzaro from Columbia.
Father with. Sorry, Mr. Bachman. Can you hear me?
I can hear you. Yes, sir.
Black man has been a long time. You know,
I got the Koran a few months
ago and then it was kinda sad.
And then my my wife, she left me
for a little bit for quite a while.
Well, Foiler, Fitch, other conduct op
ed. All that and a whole new and on hold.
So you do like some speed, you actually
do speak some Spanish, it sounds like.
Oh, yes, Mr Fact, when I speak
Spanish, but I try to speak English.
Okay. And what were your symptoms,
quali said and who seemed DOMAs?
Oh, you know, my my head hurt, you know,
I was like, oh, no, I can't can get off
to to the, you know, quantum
theory of quantum fingertip to.
Oh, and it was like a hundred Ron Swanson.
Okay, like a boy, you know, I feel better now.
And, you know, my my wife, she was gone, so
she didn't get sick. It was just me and Barry.
So, you know, now, when
you say your wife left you,
she left you just temporarily while you had the
covered. Or she just you're no longer with her.
Or she would like I had been thinking when we ran.
She just got mad at me. And, you know, she but she
was I'm trying to understand she was mad you had
the virus or she was mad about something else.
Oh, she is known me for a lot of things that
that was one reason she got mad at me. Right.
And remember, remind me,
where in Ecuador are you from?
No, from Colombia, from Colombia.
Very good. But I'm and
I'm in Texas and I'm looking forward to
Biden winning. That's my question for you
is do you think Biden has a chance in Texas?
Listen, I think he has a chance. And Joe Biden
recently made the decision to start spending
a bunch more money in Texas. He's also sending
Kamala Harris down there. So I think, Bhide, it's
close enough that Biden has determined it's worth
making a play for it. I if you say bet money,
David, who would just even money who wins Texas?
I still think Trump wins Texas, but forcing
Trump to have to defend it is a great thing.
Oh, yes. You know, I hope. I hope not.
And anyway, I hope Kamala Harris wins.
She's kind of cute, you know, right?
Well, you know, I don't appreciate
talking to you, Mr. Parkman. I love your your
discoursing. There's some very nice people.
All right. Pedro from Cook. And you're
from a copy dial, right? You told us.
No. Mr. Kaplan, I just had a headache that day.
I didn't remember where I'm from. Where are you
from? In Colombia. I have a headache now and
I don't remember where. Right or wrong? No.
Was it over with?
You'll tell me next time, OK?
All right. Pedro from Colombia
is shot out of a cannon today.